so
seeing where animals are going so you
can avoid them if they're coming after
you or if you can catch them if you're
going after them right one of the
arguably
uniquely human abilities is precision
throwing right no other animal can do
that that's a very human thing
although visual motion is shared with
lots of ability to see motion is shared
with lots of animals what else did you
notice
what else seemed funny or or
you know harder to discern with stop
motion yeah
we care about small details like the
movement to
understand what your person is saying
yeah yeah so
um
i was making notes to self i haven't
done that demo before but in future it
would be really good to have the audio
quality terrible because if the audio
quality is terrible you would lean more
on lip reading and we might have noticed
more that it's really hard to do that
probably even at relatively fast flicker
rates because that motion information is
important absolutely what else
how about beyond just lip reading what
else did you notice about the faces mine
or gems
could you yeah they were static so it
was kind of hard to tell like emotion
because like a lot of our um the ways we
express emotion is very nuanced exactly
exactly facial expressions are
incredibly subtle like little micro
expressions flicker across the face in a
tenth of a second and go away and you
guys detect them like we're we're very
very sensitive to those things you know
if somebody you know sometimes if you
see somebody in a hallway and
for a moment there's an expression that
flickers across their face and then they
give you like a normal smile but you can
tell from that expression that actually
they didn't want to see you for whatever
reason right we catch those things we're
really really good at catching those
little fleeting expressions and those
probably have to do with not just
sampling with fine temporal frequency
but probably seeing the direction of
motion of each little part of the face
okay
okay so this is just common sense
reasoning about what we might have
motion for okay and so you guys got all
the things that i had in mind okay so
now next question just kind of thought a
thought question speculation question
given the these many different things
that make motion important to us uh
biologically ecologically in our daily
lives
maybe that's important enough that we
might allocate special brain machinery
to processing motion
what do you think
important enough could you get by if you
lived in a strobe world all the time
could you survive just fine
hard to say right might be hard i mean
we probably don't need to go hunting
down predators but um you know you walk
across vassar street and there's some
pretty dangerous predators coming down
vassar street in the way of cars right
you need to know where they're going and
whether you can cross in front of them
so it's actually pretty hard
to live life without being able to see
motion and i'll tell you about a woman
who has that experience later in the
lecture
okay
next question
just think about this i'm not going to
test you on it or anything it's not the
topic of this course but it's a
perspective you should take imagine
that this were a cs course and i gave
you a segment of video
and your task was to take some to write
some code that takes that video input
and says whether objects are moving in
that movie or says which objects are
moving or how much they're moving or
what direction they're moving what kind
of code would you have to write to take
that video input to try to figure that
out
okay so just think about that we're not
going to be writing code in this class
but a lot of what we're going to be
doing is thinking about
how do you
take this kind of perceptual input and
come out with that kind of perceptual
inference
and what kinds of computations would
have to go on in between
whether those computations are going on
in code that you guys write or in a
piece of brain that's doing that
computation
and thinking about how you might might
write the code gives you really
important insights about what the brain
might be doing okay
all right
so that's the point of all of that the
the mar reading talks about all of this
and the key point we're trying to get
here is that you can't understand
perception
without thinking about what each
perceptual inference is necessary for
ecologically in daily lives
and about the computational challenges
involved in making that inference okay
so we'll get back to all that
but
next week and beyond but meanwhile
here's the agenda for today so here's
the agenda we just did the demo we're
now going to skip and do some
neuroanatomy absolutely bear basics
because on wednesday we have this
amazing opportunity to have one of the
most kind of famous neuroscientists in
the world do a dissection of a real
human brain right here right in front of
you it's going to be awesome
and i don't want to
waste that opportunity
or
embarrass ourselves by having people not
know the bare basics so we're going to
do the bare basics it's all stuff you
should know from 900 and 901 and i'm
going to whip through it fast so we can
get to more interesting stuff and get
back to visual motion okay
that's the agenda
all right so some absolute bare basics
of the brain
the human brain contains about 100
billion 10 to the 11th neurons and
that's a very big number that's such a
big number it's approximately jeff bezos
is worth well it was until mackenzie got
into the picture so we'll see
no you don't need to remember this
number just know it's a really big
number
basics of a neuron here's a neuron a
neuron is a cell like any other cell in
the body it's got a cell body and a
nucleus just like any other cell in your
body but the thing that's distinctive
about a neuron is has a big long process
called an axon it's got a bunch of
dendrites the little processes little
thingies
near the cell body and out at the tip of
the axon
that's your classic neuron many neurons
have a myelin sheath a layer of rolled
up fat around the axon
made up of other cells that makes axon
conduct neural signals faster okay you
should know all that i'm not trying to
insult your intelligence i'm just trying
to make sure everybody's with the
program here okay so you have thousands
of synapses on each neuron and that
means you have to put a technically a
shitload of synapses in your brain okay
another important point um the brain
runs on a mere 20 watts and if you're
not impressed with that
reflect on the fact that ibm's watson
runs on 20 000 watts so one of the cool
things about the human brain is not just
all the awesome stuff that we can do
that still no computer can do that i
talked about last time but also how
incredibly energetically efficiently we
do it with our human brains
so most of this course is going to talk
about the cortex that's all the stuff on
the outside of the brain it's a sheet
wrapping around the outside of the brain
that folded outer surface
it's approx approximately the size and
area of a large pizza
but there are lots of other important
bits too and i'm going to just do
whirlwind tour of those other bits
now okay so you can think of the brain
as composed of four major kinds of
components
deep down in the bottom of the brain you
have the brain stem where the spinal
cord comes in here and the rest of the
brain is up there and the brain stem is
right down here and the cerebellum this
little cauliflower-like thing that sits
out right back there
and
in the middle of the brain you have the
limbic system with a whole bunch of
subcortical regions and we'll talk about
a few of those in a moment
and you have white matter all the cables
and connections that go from one part of
the brain to another part this is an
actual dissected human brain and all
those kind of weird fibrous things are
bundles of axons connecting remote parts
of the brain to each other you can see
them in gross dissection okay
and of course you have the cortex okay
so these are just four major things to
think about and before we spend the rest
of the course on that we're going to do
just a teeny little bit on the other
major bits
okay and i'm going fast so just stop me
if any of this isn't clear
all right
so the reason we're doing this in part
is that with a dissection of a brain
some of the main things you see are
those subcortical structures right and
so even though the course is going to
focus on the cortex each little
different bit of the cortex to the naked
eye looks like any other bit of the
cortex it's the subcortical stuff that
looks different right
so that's why we're doing this okay bear
basics on the brain stem
you can think of it as a bunch of relays
in here different uh centers that
connect information coming up from the
spinal cord and send it through into the
cerebellum
so it's in many ways the most primitive
part of the brain that means it's shared
with animals very that branched off from
us very far back in in mammalian
evolution
but it's also essential to life okay so
you can get by with most of your cortex
gone like you may not have a lot of fun
you may not really know what's going on
but you will stay alive but you can't
get by without your brain stem right
it's a it controls all kinds of basic
crucial bodily functions like breathing
consciousness temporary temperature
regulation etc so it's not interesting
cognitively but it's crucial for life
cerebellum this beautiful thing here
it's basically involved in motor
coordination
but from there on out there's a huge
debate about its possible role in
cognition and so there's lots of brain
imaging studies where people find that
the cerebellum is engaged in all kinds
of things from aspects of perception up
through aspects of language
understanding you can find activations
um in brain imaging studies
nonetheless the best guess is that you
actually don't need a cerebellum uh for
any of this
so there's if anybody's interested i'm
going to actually try to remember to put
it up as an optional reading on the site
there's a recent article in the atlantic
or the new yorker
about a kid who had no cerebellum
and he learned to walk late and slow
nobody knew what his problem was but he
learned to do pretty much everything
like he's pretty much fine his motor
coordination isn't great but he's fine
yeah how are you defining consciousness
in this context oh that's a good
question and it's a big question and
it's a question that nobody knows how to
answer not just me
so christoph koh who does more of work
on the neural basis of consciousness
than just about anybody has been going
around saying for about 15 years
we must not get stuck on a premature
definition of consciousness because we
don't know what that thing is that we're
trying to understand so i'll hide behind
kristoff's uh perry of that question
and say we'll talk about it later in the
course but it's there are many different
kind of ways of defining it from the
difference of difference between being
awake versus asleep which is some of the
functions that go on here the difference
between
being kind of knocked out and completely
unconscious under general anesthesia
which is different from being asleep
those kind of states of consciousness
are regulated in part in here yeah
okay so you can get by without a
cerebellum but it's not recommended
um moving right along all those
subcortical bits we're just going to
talk about three of the most important
ones the thalamus this big guy right
smack in the middle of the brain very
large structure
the hippocampus and the amygdala okay
let's talk about the thalamus
think about the thalamus as a grand
central station of the brain okay with
all of these connections going to all
those parts of cortex coming in and out
of the thalamus like that okay
so one of the key things about the
thalamus
is that most of the incoming sensory
information goes by way of the thalamus
on route to the cortex
okay so if you start with your ear
there's sensory endings in your ear that
we'll talk about later in the term and
they send
neurons into this thalamus here this
yellow thing
through a bunch of different stages they
make a stop in the thalamus and then
they come up here to this green patch
which is auditory cortex
okay
similarly
somatosensory endings touch sensors in
your skin that enable you to feel when
you're being touched
come in through the skin
and they make a stop in the thalamus and
then they go up to somatosensory cortex
up there
okay
similarly
signals that come in from your eyes
make a stop in the thalamus
and then go up to visual cortex
okay what's the name of the structure in
the thalamus that those axons make a
synapse in coming up from the eyes you
make a synapse here and you go up oops
you go up to visual cortex
lgn perfect what does it stand for
perfect okay you should know that it's
this is review from
900 901 okay
um yes sorry okay
which sensory modality does not go
through the thalamus on route to cortex
between the sensory nerve endings and
the cortex
sorry
yes yes you guys are on the ball yes
olfactory system is the one sensory
modality that doesn't make a stop in the
cortex
you can sort of see that here from the
nose it goes straight up into
olfactory cortex right there
all right so that's the um
standard view of the thalamus as this
kind of like relay station where all the
external sensory information comes in
there makes a stop and then goes up to
cortex okay
that's my thalamus act boom like that
right okay
but
uh increasingly there's evidence that
the thalamus is much more than a relay
station and why would you bother with a
relay anyway kind of doesn't mean
anything kind of means like we don't
know what's going on here because you
wouldn't just make a synapse for no
reason right um okay and so the first
thing to note is there are lots of
connections that go back down the other
way there are ten times as many
connections that go from primary visual
cortex right here in me
right here in the sky in red there are
ten times as many that go backwards
down to the thalamus
as go forwards
that's mind-blowing right information
comes from the eyes up into the brain
what the hell are those things doing
going backwards okay
well they're doing all kinds of
interesting things so that's the first
indication that the thalamus isn't just
relaying stuff in a stupid passive way
and the second whole line of work which
many people are working on but i think
some of the most awesome work on this
topic is done by our own mike halasa in
this department
and he does these incredible studies
that you can do in mice with these
spectacular methods that we can't use in
humans
where he can really take apart the
circuit in magnificent detail
and he's showing that the thalamus is
involved in all kinds of high-level
cognitive computations in mice it's
really stunning work when the mice have
to switch from doing one task to another
the thalamus plays a key role in gating
the flow of information from one
cortical region to another
okay
all right moving along they hit the
campus i know you guys all learn about
this the number one gripe in this
department is we learn about hm in every
course so that's going to happen here
but it's going to last about 20 seconds
so here it goes that's a normal slice of
the brain like this here's the
hippocampus on either side it's like a
whole curled up deal right there and
right there
and here is hm's brain the famous hm who
had surgery to remove his hippocampus on
both sides and completely lost his
episodic memory for anything that
happened after his surgery okay you all
remember that right
if anybody hasn't heard of hm send me an
email i'll give you some background
reading
okay so very loosely the hippocampus
involved both in this kind of long-term
episodic memory that hm lost and it also
plays a key role in navigation which
we'll talk about in
great detail in a few weeks
and i just want to say that some cases
are even more extreme than hm
so there's a case of lonnie sue johnson
and i am trying to get you guys a video
and i didn't get it in time but i'll
show it to you later in the term if
you're interested
lonnie sue johnson had a viral infection
that went up into her brain she was an
extremely accomplished person she did
illustrations on the cover of the new
yorker she was a pilot she had her own
farm when she raised you know lots of
lots of stuff
a very smart interesting multi-talented
woman who had this
terrible tragedy of getting viral
encephalitis at i don't know what age
but middle age
and she now does not remember a single
event in her life
she's smart she's funny her personality
is totally intact
she can answer questions she can paint
she can do all kinds of things but she
does not remember a single event in her
life
that's pretty astonishing
reflect on what it means to have a sense
of self if you don't remember anything
in your life yeah she remember her again
that's a good question i'm not sure she
might know her yes she does know her
name actually it is evident in this
video but the video well so you know she
doesn't remember at one point in this
video she's asked were you ever married
and she's lovely and sweet and gentle
and kind of low-key and she's like you
know
just don't remember i might have been i
might have been she was married for 10
years
so uh that's the hippocampus important
you don't want to lose that one yeah
about each other if the campus is using
long-term memory why is it that it being
removed causing to not form new memories
well so long-term memory means you know
it's a vague term it means the formation
rich and retrieval of memories that are
going to last a long time
so in hm's case he can access a lot of
the memories from before his injury
in lonnie sue's case she can't do even
that
okay
all right
amygdala
okay amygdala is a greek word that means
almond because the amygdala is the size
and shape of an almond
and so
just for fun we're passing on her own my
favorite kind have some almonds and pass
them around all right
um
okay so the amygdala is involved in
experiencing and recognizing emotions
especially fear
the simple statement that you should
remember about what the amygdala does
is just remember the four f's you guys
all know about the four f's
fighting fleeing feeding and mating
okay
patient sm
lost her amygdala on both sides
okay
she cannot experience fear
she doesn't recognize fear on facial
expressions of other people and she
doesn't experience fear herself
okay and so that's a the striking um
piece of evidence on what the amygdala
does her face recognition is normal
recognizing identities
her iq is normal
she's overly trusting of other people
okay
um okay so that's all you need to know
about the amygdala for now
um okay let's talk about white matter
just brief review here's a here's a kind
of tunnel through a piece of cortex okay
so my brain cortex is wrapping around
like that if we took a piece like this
just took a segment out like that this
is the outside of the brain up there
cortex runs like this
and gray matter is the stuff on the
outer surface that's full of cell bodies
okay
white matter
are the axons the processes that come
out of those cell bodies and travel
elsewhere in the brain
okay everybody clear on that okay so
we've got gray matter up here and white
matter down there
mostly myelinated axons that have that
layer of fat to make them conduct fast
and so you'll see bundles of white
matter in the dissection
and so here's an actual picture
photograph of the slice through a brain
so all that white stuff up there is
white matter okay
and so you might say well it's just a
big bunch of wires
who cares about that
it's a good question but actually the
wires are pretty damn interesting and
pretty fundamental
and so i'll just give you a few reasons
and you don't need to memorize every one
of these i'm just trying to give you a
gist of why we might care about this and
there will be a whole other lecture on
networks and connectivity later in the
course well first of all white matter is
45 of the human brain
okay so takes up a lot of space all
those wires connecting one bit to
another bit
and i would say we cannot possibly
understand the cortex and how it works
or any little piece of it without
knowing the connectivity of each piece
to each other bit of the cortex right
imagine trying to understand a computer
or a circuit without being able to see
the connections between the bits like it
would drive you crazy that's a situation
we're in now in human cognitive
neuroscience it frankly drives me insane
but that's where we are
um
next thing
the long-range connectivity of each
little bit of cortex some little bit
right there in my brain is connected to
some bunch of other remote regions in my
brain and that particular set of
connections is distinctive for that
patch of cortex
so you can think of it as a connectivity
fingerprint of a patch of cortex
okay so one of the ways that the
different bits differ from each other is
by way of their connectivity
fingerprints
and i'm going to skip the rest of these
because we're going to get back to them
later
and i'm going to run out of time i'm
going to assign the tas to sound the
gong at 12 15. okay good
all right
now we're up to the cortex this is
really laughably
shallow but whatever that's what we're
doing here
so here's this cortex and as i mentioned
it's a whole big sheet and the different
bits look really similar if you just
look at them or slice them up
so how are we going to figure out how
this thing is organized
well
okay now we're up here talking about
cortex all right let's start with the
easy parts which you've already seen
you've already seen this up here these
colored bits visual cortex auditory
cortex
um
somatosensory cortex
gustatory taste cortex
those bits
are like the easy parts of cortex those
are called primary sensory regions
there's also motor cortex right in front
of sensory cortex so those are the
primary regions
their primary in the sense of this is
the first place that sensory information
lands up at the cortex coming up from
the senses right
okay
um
and all of that input is wired through
what structure
yes thank you
um so how are these regions organized
um well they have maps every one of
these regions has a map
and each of them has a map of a
different thing so let's start with
visual cortex
and we're going to talk about the map
that lives in visual cortex but the
prior condition for understanding that
map is to understand the concept of
receptive field which you should know so
i'm going to whip through it quickly
okay so here is how you map the
receptive field as a property of an
individual cell
in a brain okay so the classic way in
animal neuroscience is you place an
electrode in the brain next to a neuron
in monkey visual cortex
okay so here's this monkey's gun
electrode right in his brain right next
to a neuron and visual cortex and every
time that neuron fires
you get a spike you hear a spike okay
now you train the monkey to stare at a
fixation spot without moving its eyes
okay i can do this with humans without
training you i can just tell you look at
the tip of my nose okay so keep your
eyes on the tip of my nose i can see if
you're looking elsewhere so look at the
tip of my nose okay okay so you train a
monkey to do that that takes a few
months and then they can do that
and then while recording from neurons in
his brain you put stimuli over here put
a flash over there or a flash over here
or a flash over here or flash over here
okay you can stop looking at my nose
it's not all that fabulous knows i
realize okay
so a receptive field
is the place in the visual world that
makes a given neuron fire
okay so if there's a neuron in your
brain that responds to a flash here but
not a flash here or here or here or here
the receptive field of that neuron is
right there everybody got that idea
okay so in visual cortex neurons have
restricted receptive fields they don't
respond to anything anywhere in the
visual field they respond to a
particular place in space
okay if that's confusing at all ask a
question because it will come up again
and again
all right so that's what the rest of
this slide says what i just said blah
blah blah doesn't matter that's a
receptive field different visual neurons
have different receptive fields
for different parts of space
now here comes the important idea in
visual cortex two neurons that are next
to each other in visual cortex have
nearby receptive fields
okay
so that's the concept of retina topi
or the map in visual cortex so you
basically have a map of the visual world
in your visual cortex because there's
this systematic layout just like you
have in your retina in your retina
visual information comes in and because
of optics different parts of your retina
respond to different parts of the image
but that information is propagated back
through the lgn up to primary visual
cortex where you still have a map of the
visual space up in primary visual cortex
okay
so that map is called retinotopic in
visual cortex because it's
oriented like the retina
and so here's a particularly kind of
gruesome but very literal depiction of
this property of retina topi
in a monkey brain this is an experiment
done very long ago by roger tutel
and what he did was um
he used a method called deoxyglucose and
so what deoxyglucose
is a molecule that's a whole lot like
glucose
but it's got one little change in the
molecule which means it gets stuck on
the metabolic chain and so it gets taken
up by cells that want to take up glucose
and then it gets stuck in there and
can't be broken down so it builds up in
cells that are metabolically active
okay so you can put a little radioactive
tracer on deoxyglucose
inject it into a person or an animal and
what happens is it builds up with this
radioactive tag on all the cells that
were active makes sense
okay so tutel did an experiment where
he had the monkey fixate on a spot
and he presented this stimulus here so
the monkey's fixating right there and
the stimulus is flashing on and off
he injects the radioactive deoxyglucose
into the monkey while the monkey's
looking at this
and then i'm sorry to say he killed the
monkey
rolled out visual cortex into a sheet
and there it is
and you can see the bullseye pattern
that the monkey was looking at across
the surface of visual cortex
does everybody get that
okay so that shows you very literally
what a retinotopic map is in the brain
it's just like the map of the visual
world in the retina but there it is up
in the back of the brain and humans have
this too
okay
and so this can be shown in humans with
functional mri we'll talk later more
about the methods of functional mri but
here's a very high resolution functional
mri experiment done by some people over
at mgh charlestown by the way when i
have names on slides
it's just because in science we don't
get paid that much and so our credit for
our cool data is kind of all we have and
so i can't stand to talk about other
people's cool experiments without giving
them credit i do not expect you to learn
the names it's just my little personal
tic that i need to have their name there
to give them credit even though you
don't know who they are okay
okay so what this guy john palomani did
was show human subjects this stimulus
here they were fixating right there and
the stimulus is flickering with the dots
kind of dancing around
and then he looked on the back in visual
cortex on the surface of the brain
and he sees an n there
it's the same stimulus it's just flipped
upside down which is not deeper
interesting the cortex has to be
oriented one way or another the brain
doesn't care whether you turn it around
right and your map of visual space is
upside down in the back of the head
and you see that m
does everybody get how that also shows
retinotopic properties in the brain
in human visual cortex
okay
all right so the key idea of retina
toppy is that adjacent parts of the
visual seal field are mapped to adjacent
parts of the cortex
all right
okay a little bit of terminology just
because
people are fast and loose with these
things i've already referred to v1 and
primary visual cortex it's also
sometimes called striat cortex it's all
the same thing it's the part of the
visual cortex where the information
first comes up from the lgn right back
here
so in me it's right there most of it is
in the space between the two hemispheres
but a little bit sticks out on the side
so in this person that yellowy orange
stuff that's primary visual cortex which
is the same as v1 and striat cortex okay
that's just terminology
all right just as we have maps for
visual space we have maps for touch
space and so you've probably seen this
diagram here of the map of touch space
going across somatosensory cortex like
this so this is a picture of a slice
like that showing you which parts of the
body are mapped out to which parts of
space
and you can see that particularly
important parts of the body get bigger
bits of cortex
yeah
okay
just as we have visual maps and touch
maps we have auditory maps in auditory
cortex which is right on the top of the
temporal lobe right in here
and which is what's mapped out in
auditory cortex is auditory frequency
high versus low versus high
frequencies of sound and so you see that
here's a piece of auditory cortex in one
subject showing you
regions that respond to high frequencies
low frequencies high frequencies here it
is another subject high low high another
subject high low high
okay
so the point of all of this
is that primary sensory cortex has maps
everybody clear on this the different
sensory modalities map different
dimensions
okay
so what about the rest of cortex like
you can see most of the cortex is not
primary sensory cortex
is the rest of cortex just mush or are
there separate bits like primary sensory
areas
and if so do those other bits have maps
and if so
what are those maps of
okay we just took you from 100 years ago
to the cutting edge of the field is
asking this question in lots of
different ways right now
okay
okay let's back up and ask what counts
as a cortical area anyway i just posited
that these primary sensory regions count
as distinct things they're like the
things right they're separate things in
the brain okay and if for no other
reason then they get direct input from
the thalamus
right
okay
um
but let's back up and ask what exactly
is a cortical area
and we're going to consider this
question
um
by considering the three key criteria
for what counts as a cortical area
okay the first one
is that that region of cortex is
distinct from its neighbors in function
neurons their fire in response to
something different from the neurons in
the neighboring region okay that's very
vague right now but we'll illustrate
that
the next one as i mentioned this before
each distinct
region of cortex has a different set of
connections to other parts of the brain
it has a distinct connectivity
fingerprint
okay
and the third thing is
for at least some regions of the cortex
they're physically different if you
slice them up and stain them and look at
them really carefully they might look a
little different than other bits of the
cortex
okay
so those are three of the key criteria
that have been used to say this bit of
cortex it's a thing right it's distinct
right
okay
so let's look at the classic example
beyond those primary regions those are
the most classic regions the primary
regions we've already talked about those
are the ones nobody would fight you on
that this one is next in line nobody
will fight you of say if you say visual
area mt
that's an area well they might but most
people wouldn't okay and then from there
on out it's all fighting all the time
okay so let's talk about visual area mt
it's a little patch of the cortex and a
monkey brain this is a side view of a
monkey brain
and in this human brain it's that little
patch right there
okay
so
this region meets all the criteria to be
a distinct visual area
so how do we know this
well we know this from lots and lots of
different methods so i'm going to whip
through a few of those to give you a
gist of how we can find evidence that
that region is distinct in function
connectivity and
the physical stuff sometimes called cyto
architecture
okay
all right
function how would we know that region
respon has a different function
well one way the classic way is to
record from individual neurons in monkey
brains
so if you stick a neuron into monkey
visual cortex while the monkey is
looking at the stimulus
that i'll show you in a second you'll
hear the responses of an individual
neuron each clique will be the response
of an individual neuron to the stimulus
so let's play this thing
except it's not making any sound chris
can you help me
oh right
duh
that part
okay see when the bar of light moves
this way it makes a lot of firing
and not when it moves the other way
let's watch it for a second watch the
bar move again
[Applause]
so he responds less when it's moving in
a different direction ready got that
what is this area right there called
yeah this area right here in the middle
exactly that's a receptive field that's
a part of visual space that makes this
neuron fire
okay this neuron also has a property
called direction it's sensitive to
motion as you see but it's also
specific to specific directions of
motion everybody see that
okay
so that's a direction selective neuron
in monkey area mt
and here's a way of showing with data
what you guys just saw
this is a map of different directions in
polar coordinates and this shows you how
much
this is a this is a single cell being
described here this is the direction
selectivity of that cell showing you
that when motion moves when the stimulus
moves in this direction you get a lot of
firing when it moves in this direction
you get less firing and can everybody
see how this plot shows you the
direction selectivity of that cell makes
sense
right
okay so that shows you what you just saw
in the movie
so this is one way to establish the
function
of visual area mt is stick electrodes in
there and record directly from them
when a monkey looks at different kinds
of stimuli and you see direction
selectivity when you do that
okay
further
if you actually do this systematically
moving across next door bits
of
monkey area mt
what you find is that as we said before
nearby bits of cortex respond to similar
things in this case to similar
directions of motion so here's a little
diagram as you move across the cortex
you see a systematic change in the
direction selectivity of neurons as you
move across the cortex
so in mt
we have a map of direction preference
just as we had a map of
spatial location in primary visual
cortex make sense
okay now because those neurons are
clustered like that
i forget what my next point was no never
mind we'll get that in a second okay
what about humans okay so here's a
monkey brain here's a neuron and a
monkey brain what about humans can we
record from single neurons in humans
what do you think
do we ever get to do that
yeah
yeah
yeah
neurosurgeons very occasionally enable
us to record from individual neurons in
human brains it's the most awesome data
ever
of course we only do it when the
neurosurgeons have decided for clinical
reasons to put electrodes in human
brains they need to do this to map out
epilepsy before surgery and sometimes
those patients are super nice and say
yes i'll look at your stimuli or listen
to your stimuli while you record from my
neurons and then we get the most awesome
data ever but it's very very rare i
don't know of any data where people have
reported individual neurons in area mt
in humans yeah so how powerful should an
fmri be to be able to ignore such
information oh we're getting there
okay so given that we very rarely
uh get uh get to record from individual
neurons in humans and we want to know
more generally
if there is an mt in humans what do we
do
we pop subjects in an mri scanner
and we show them moving dots or
stationary dots
and we scan them with functional mri
we'll go through the details of how this
works more in future lectures but what
you see basically is this is a slice
through the brain like this
and you see this region right here
responds more
to the moving dots this is the response
to the time here this is when the moving
dots are on high response and then what
switches to stationary dots
the response drops
okay so with functional mri you can also
find visual area mt by the higher
response to moving than stationary dots
does that make sense more or less i mean
i'm not giving you any of the details
but for now they don't really matter
okay
so that's cool
but does that tell us
that neurons in human mt are specific
for the direction of motion
yes
moving in a specific motion removing in
all the directions you see here
no it doesn't
it tells us it's sensitive to the
presence of motion but not the direction
of motion
okay
so if if we want to really know is human
mt like monkey empty or is this really
human empty we want to know are the
neurons in there not just responsive to
motion but are neurons specific for
particular directions of motion
okay
so
how would we do that okay
uh well there's lots of ways of doing
that but actually one of the charming
things is you can do that without an mri
scanner that is it won't tell you
whether it's empty you're looking at but
we can ask the question of whether your
brains have neurons that are tuned for
particular directions
so for this demo i want you to
fixate right in the center and do not
move your eyes from that dot
and i'm going to keep talking for a
while while you keep fixating right on
that dot
and so what we're going to what i'm
going to show you is something called an
after effect this is also known as the
psychophysicist's electrode
psychophysicists are people who just
measure behavior and from behavior they
can infer how individual neurons work
and that is about as awesome as it gets
that's much more impressive than just
recording from the damn neuron inferring
from very indirect data how the neuron
works from behavior now that is pretty
oops okay sorry look directly at my face
you see anything i didn't see it stop oh
crap we're gonna oh here we go
uh oh right okay just fixate on the
center again sorry i forgot this guy was
going to stop
so keep looking at the center
and then when it stops in a little bit
then keep your eyes right on that dot
and you can see what happens
oh that's right good point yes right now
it's alternating nothing's gonna happen
but that's okay we're gonna have the
whole experience keep fixating on the
dot
it's good the tas are on the ball
okay fix it on the dot
anybody see anything
not really
that's okay you're not supposed to
that's the control condition it was
alternating directions okay so i think
it's going to start moving again
i'm not sure let's go back let's just
start it again okay sorry i blew it the
first time but let's just get this right
okay fixate on the center
and just keep your eyes right on that
center
so this one it's not alternating
and it's going to do this for around 30
seconds
and so the whole point of this is this
is a way with behavior to ask the
question of whether you have neurons in
your brain tuned to specific directions
of motion
and something as low-tech and simple as
an after effect can tell you that
keep looking
did you guys see anything
what'd you see
what happened
it wasn't even exactly something they
kind of like
did it well it actually should
well now it's doing something else but
it should shrink at the end did you guys
see it shrink
okay so that's an after effect and the
simple version of the story is that you
are tiring out your neurons that are
sensitive to outward motion while you
stare at all that outward motion and
after you kind of burn them out and
exhaust them
then when you look at something
stationary it looks like it's going
inward
okay
and the general idea is you have pools
of neurons that the the easiest way to
account for that is you have pools of
neurons tuned for different directions
and that's why if you tire out one batch
you have a net signal in the other
direction does that make sense
this is all very relevant to your
assignment which is due tomorrow night
at 6.
this phenomenon was used in the scanner
for that experiment and you can think
about
um how you would use this phenomenon
um to ask whether there's direction
selectivity not just responses to motion
in human mt
yeah wait uh i'm just a little bit
confused so even when an image is like
completely still like even if you're not
detecting motion those neurons are still
firing
ah
um that's a good question but but most
likely it's the simple cases
if this may have not worked beautifully
in part because i screwed it up and
didn't notice when it stopped
but if it works well you should get a
pretty powerful sense that after you see
it expanding then when it's still it
should seem to be contracting
so when that happens
the reading assigned for today tomorrow
tomorrow night tells you what happens in
your brain during that time when you are
looking at stationary stimuli but
experiencing motion
so there's no motion in the stimulus but
there's motion in your percept
okay so that's the question
right so read the paper and find out
yeah
all right
all right so all of that
tells us just that there are neurons
some place in your brain that are
sensitive to the direction of motion
it doesn't tell us that they're in mt in
particular
but the assigned reading will talk about
that
okay
right a further bit of evidence
is remember i said how in monkeys next
door bits in mt have have have similar
direction selectivity
that means you can also inject an
electrical signal in a little patch of
mt
and give the monkey a net percept of a
direction of motion
okay
if all the neurons were scrambled around
spatially so that there was no
clustering of neurons sensitive to say
this direction of motion then
stimulation wouldn't do anything
but if you train a monkey to tell you
what direction of motion he's seeing and
you show them just random dots that
aren't moving in any direction and you
stimulate one little patch
it'll tell you the direction of motion
of the neurons in that little patch
and that is much more powerful evidence
that that region
is not only responsive to motion but
causally involved in your perception of
motion
okay i'm a little obsessed with this
distinction between
you know recording responses and
establishing causality so we'll go over
this in more detail later but i want you
to start getting used to that idea
another way to test the causal role of
area mt
in
motion is
with patients with brain damage and area
mt
so there's one famous patient who had
brain damage right there
which is right where mt usually is
and she could not see motion and she
reports all kinds of things like
difficulty crossing the street
difficulty catching balls
difficulty pouring water into a cup
okay just as you guys saw earlier that's
called akinatopsia
right can it like kinetics motion a not
motion right opsia eyes
okay
um
all right so i started with these
criteria for what makes something a
visual a
distinct area and one piece of evidence
is function and i just gave you a whole
bunch of different kinds of evidence for
distinct function and visual area mt
that it's specifically involved in
motion
processing
and the two other criteria which are
getting short shrift but i'll just toss
them off and we'll return to them
one is the distinct connectivity of that
region
okay so you may have seen this horrific
wiring diagram of visual cortex in
monkeys i think it comes up in like half
the talks and classes in in my field
this is the one down here and so there's
lots and lots of different visual areas
and there's a whole fancy wiring diagram
and smack in the middle of this diagram
that's visual area mt and if you blow
this up and stare at it you'll see that
mt has a particular set of connections
to other visual regions and cortex and
its particular set of connections are
different from the connections of any of
those other regions it's part of its
connectivity fingerprint or signature
and that's another piece of evidence
that it's a thing
okay it's not just another like
amorphous bit of cortex it's a
particular thing in the brain
and finally you might wonder is that bit
of cortex physically different are the
cells in there different are the layers
of cortex different
um in any way
and from
and you may remember from probably 900
about brodman areas like this dude
corbinian brodeman
sliced up lots of dead brains looked at
them under a microscope and argued that
were there were 52 different parts just
from what it looked like if you slice
them up under a microscope okay so we
called those brodman areas and area 17
this primary visual cortex comes from
brodman's terminology
um
and so he argued that there he thought
these were distinct organs in the brain
and he even inferred the specific
histological differentiation of the
cortical areas proves irrefutably their
specific functional differentiation well
it doesn't but never mind kind of
sounded good
anyway that was his idea
and these kinds of distinct
kind of cellular physical anatomical
differences are very salient for primary
cortical areas
for vision and audition and touch
and motor cortex but they're much
muckier for lots of other areas
one important exception which is why we
chose this is area mt
and so i'll end in one minute but just
to tell you where this is going this is
a flattened piece of monkey cortex
rolled out like with a baking roller no
i don't know some something like that so
here's monkey cortex and there's v1 and
v2 and it's a big mess but that big dark
blob this bit of cortex is stained with
something called cytochrome oxidase
and that indicates metabolic activity
mt neurons are very highly metabolically
active and so here's a map
of visual cortex and that exactly is
area mt
so area mt actually is
histologically or
psychoarchitectonically
different from its neighbors
and hence fits all of the criteria for a
cortical area
okay i went one minute over i realize i
threw out a lot of terminology i don't
want you to memorize too much so i made
a list of the kinds of things that you
should understand from this lecture the
things that i think are important
you